die letzten zwei tage hatten das erst
mal ein bisschen reduziert und ich
fühlte mich schwach jetzt habe ich noch
mehr genießen letzte abend auf der nackt
insel ich habe eine krone bekommen
mein name ist für biermann den bild
reportern als traum reportage habe ich
mir überlegt auf den philippinen
zufrieden auf eine mini insel ja
initiieren der macht angekommen und es
ist auf jeden fall kann man sieht immer
dass mir ja ich muss sagen das ist mir
ziemlich unangenehm es war
nackt zeigen langsam gewöhne ich mich
schon ein bisschen dran ich guck mal wie
ich will seinerseits wunderschön hier
die es gibt
nun die nachtflügen auf den strand
andererseits
die auf einem krassen fehler sie bringt
jeden dazu grüne 6 gewichtigen nach
alter käse und sie meint jetzt schon
dass ich auch eine meiner mahlzeiten
durch die grünen werte ersetzen
aber das habe ich mich jetzt noch
abwehren
[Musik]
[Applaus]